[Music]
now everybody laughed when I talked
about Trump voters but if you actually
look at the facts 28% of Hispanic voters
voted for Trump
27% of Asian voters voted for Trump 8%
of black voters voted for Trump so
unless you think oh they're all mad or
they're stupid it cannot be the case
that Trump is just appealing to the Ku
Klux Klan right that doesn't pass
intellectual muster what is what they
are doing and what they're doing from
Victor Orban from the polls alternative
for Deutschland for Nationale is they
are the only project talking solidarity
and overwhelmingly they are the
supporter by working-class votes those
on on the left and the right who don't
talk solidarity overwhelmingly
middle-class who unbeknownst to
themselves of following individualist
projects that will not help
working-class people I think don't take
issue with people not talking solidarity
can you imagine the Labour Party not
talking solidarity yeah what what
happens what happens when you have
debates like this and you and you talk
about it in this academic forum in terms
of identity politics what happens when
you have a Alpha white male on the panel
and you decide you know listen how do
you can and you disagree you will turn
around and say as you said you I don't
understand what you're saying and so
that's what you've said to me that I
don't understand what you're saying
because I disagreed with what you said
now if you think that Trump didn't
appeal to a certain group of people then
I think you're mistaken he knew exactly
what he was doing that's where he went
to the smaller states and and spoke the
language of hate not solidarity or paint
in a certain way to build your ability
to come in because to build his base
that's why you have somebody like Stacey
Abrams
trying in Atlanta to to actually speak
of solidarity to try and unite both
Democrats and Republicans and talk about
a national level in terms of making sure
that every vote counts a regardless of
who you vote for ensuring their every
vote counts that's true
nationalism I mean what's good for the
country rather than what's good for
individuals so that is the difference in
terms of when people talk about identity
politics or nationalization but
everybody everybody talks about it in a
term that suits them and that is the
issue and the problem so I do have issue
with some of what you have said in
regards to how you've identified
identity politics because I don't see in
those terms we have to move on and I
talked about solidarity and the Labour
Party talks about solidarity all the
time my manifesto was built on
solidarity that's the whole premise of
the Labour Party in terms of solidarity
and for the many but and what that's
absolutely true you just need to
practice it a bit better for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you